from aubry
hello my swarthy host
hello audrey how are you
i was out on the town recently and met
some new people who were really fun and
yes some were men i wasn't out on the
prowl but it's always an option when
you're young and single however i tend
to dress slightly more conservative than
other girls and they tend to get more
immediate attention from guys because
let's face it
men are easily distracted
now i'm not dressing like a nun but
sometimes i'm a little more subtle about
accentuating my assets you feel
i feel i feel but i think that immediate
attention can lead to conversations and
sometimes turn into a more long-term
interest as a man of decent values who
isn't blind should i dress a little more
provocative to get more initial
attention and then show them my dazzling
personality
sincerely a lady in the streets
you should
dress to look beautiful
okay and so i'm not saying you should
put a you know a burka on
okay i'm not saying you should throw a
potato sack over yourself no you should
certainly
show off your beautiful qualities not
just
uh
emotional but also physical
but that doesn't mean that you should
dress like a trollop my dear
you know
i'm harkening back to my single days
when i'd go go meet the ladies around
town and yes it's true if a gal is
wearing you know dental floss it will
catch your attention but you will form
an opinion about that and very likely
your you will not look at that woman as
though this is going to be the mother of
my children it can happen but it's not
usual
whereas if you see a gal who is wearing
a potato sack yes you should you might
not pay attention to her but but if you
see a woman who is
not dressed like a
gal of ill-repute but who is still
beautiful is showing off her beauty in a
way that is
reasonable i think that's the course you
want to go on our society sets up a ton
of false dichotomies we were talking
about the false dichotomy earlier
between freedom and tyranny or whatever
liberty and censorship
we also have this false dichotomy of you
know you've either got to dress like a
street walker or you've got to
you know hide yourself in a burqa but
there's a middle ground you can you can
acknowledge beauty and even accentuate
beauty without having it be tawdry
hope that helps
i'm so glad that you enjoyed that clip
you can get the whole show it's the
michael knowles show it's very easy to
remember because i'm michael noel that's
the name of the show you can get it at
apple podcast spotify stitch or google
play wherever you get your podcast head
on over there right now get your phone
up
if you don't mind
uh pull up there you go pull up that app
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you